welcome to this video not six coverage
of the Norway chess tournament yeah
let's get right into the action looking
at the first couple of games we're
starting with aronia against Gary um
yeah match of two players with very
different experiences the wrong before
aronian lost this long battle against
cards very disappointing after he had a
very good position by Gary had won
against to pull off in a somewhat lucky
men are being lost them quite clearly at
one point and then in fact him instead
he won the game now we have this
symmetrical English here with III the
same line that Carlton had played
against Gary in the in the very first
round and yeah now curious playing
differently in the very first round here
played on the capture and then g6 I
think I entity did he start with Quincy
70 it was this kind of setup at least
somewhat to grow and flourish let's say
um this time after you three yet plate e
six completely differently and with this
we transpose to a position that normally
arises from the Queens gambit semi
tirage and it's a an isolated to Queen
porn position a very typical one in fact
I always thought that white should have
a little something here being the more
active in the center but the way Gary
played this here would be six I thought
was really convincing if we look at this
just a couple of moves later and all
this seems very normal I think around
here black already has a fairly
comfortable position it's not like he's
better or anything but I think like it
can be very satisfied with the whole
thing I
watched some minutes of the press
conference and they both agree that
blacks opening result was quite nice 96
very interesting idea trying to get to
their Foursquare and it's not so easy
for wider to avoid this g3 move you
don't really want something to pop up on
f4 but g3 is not to move your love to
play with the bishop on c4 and not this
the bishop on c4 always seems kind of
weak the right position young age for on
now Knight f6 plate challenging the
night and white has no real choice he
needs situated and the more pieces are
being traded him the Simplot becomes
would like to play the position around
here I think aronian already wasn't in
damage control mode not getting yet
travel too much he decided to trade
things off and then Queen g6 was played
quite an inconvenient move to face but
quite strong black now is almost before
swinging upon which should be seven we
should be five and white cannot really
save the deep on it came to this with
black just being a pawn up but then the
good thing is we have opposite colored
bishops and this in fact should secure
the draw for might we see that whole
green side is traded and here four
against three with this opposite colored
bishops is pretty easy win especially
concerned easy when easy draw here of
course especially considering that black
is not managing to activate his forces
if we imagine a position that
theoretically speaking a pawn on e5 and
the bishop on d4 then the rook entering
putting pressure on the poor near this
kind of fantasy variation this would be
nice would like but you never get there
as why this is
active and you can always with Lucan c8
basically keep the bishop es a bishop
move would allow the rook trades and
after Luke trades it's totally dead yes
I they shuffled a little chat chapter
there is simply nothing going on and
here they agree to a draw yeah very
unspectacular game where it just seems
that aronian was caught wrong-footed in
the opening in a way it does not seem
like all this is is giving wide that
much a bit surprising in in my book I
mean Bishop d3 years the somewhat
slightly more popular option here but
leading to a same similar position but
with the bishop here but still I thought
this would be a very serious way for off
a wide to try to play for an edge but it
does not really appear to be a that
promising okay the next move is that I'm
going to look is octa Stein octa Stein
somehow having trouble with his name
against Cara wanna and corona had lost
in the last round this this weird game
against chrome liquid was basically a
very dry end game and then he made a
very simple mistake yeah today we see
right from with 1d6 is sort of telling
the other guy okay I want to beat you
and this is at least on this level it's
quite a serious message that it is it is
a game that like wants to win he's
offering the pills pills defense with a
four or a modern but uh Christine is not
going for that is playing a very solid
set up with g3 dumb c5 played yeah black
ones out of the the long theoretical
lines and play a somewhat a symmetrical
game also
senior with Queen B 6 directly attacking
the night but why it finds the nurse
reply he just plays Bishop e3 offering
the beetle porn ya can't black take the
pawn it always needs to be checked my
term of course being a technology one he
needs to play 92 and it has a very nice
development now I think the whole
business is very risky for black white
it's got everything out and of course
this is not possible I'm sorry than a 1x
first you need to play up here something
like that is terrible for black yeah he
didn't take it he played Queen to a5
getting out of the discovery with the
night and now I'm gonna keep it simple
manner Queen d2 plate yeah the trade and
like new playing a six to prevent 95 the
whole thing looks nice for white is good
very much better development but white
has 11 problem in the positions is a
night on d to when the light would be on
c3 it could easily jump right into the
thick of things and guarantee white some
plain but in this position it's not so
easy to to make any headway and d5 was I
think a strong move at got rid of the
central night and the d6 porn is not
really a serious weakness as wide as
absolutely you have not coordinated to
attack the pawn the bishop only three
for example is far away from attacking
it and so we got this this type of
position here where after long castles I
think blankets is certainly okay the
question is however what happens after
94 at first it seems that this is a very
very awkward pin but black has an
interesting technical solution he takes
on e4 bishop d 8 and now takes on e 2
quite funny this kind of desperado night
which secures that black is getting at
least a pawn for the exchange why it
took here took on d 8 and now like a
sacrifice the exchange for porn but he
also has some other advantages is very
sound porn structure to pawn islands
against them free porn upon islands on
the white side white has numerous
somewhat weak pawns and why does not
affect terribly well coordinated
especially the night on b3 is misplaced
so I guess black has a full compensation
form for the material Bishop d5 was
played exchanging the the bishop or
initiating this trade around here we get
to this position we're still like a
enjoys very substantial compensation for
the for the exchange it's only a
question if black can can make any any
serious headway it's not totally
apparent to me in the curse of the game
the curse and the course of the game the
curse of the game doesn't sound right um
web like it could have done much better
than then what then what he played yeah
this sounds or this looks fairly logical
but right now gets the night activated
and also this trade in it's very
difficult to to get anything substantial
yes what has the the pawns that year
that he can attack in the game check we
had those trades and it's clear that
black has a fine position but can you
really win the game very very difficult
I think white has a very serious
location on the line
squares it's very difficult to to get
the pawn moving for example the III porn
or the H porn for that matter and with a
4b five white has managed to activate
his his rooks in fact only a couple of
moves later exactly here they agreed to
a draw the simple fact being that rook
f7 which wasn't played out but Luke f7
rook t5 and then the capture both
captures actually but yeah kind of stuff
leads to a position where black has
absolutely nowhere no winning chance
white can also take with this check and
can give a perpetual here yeah let's say
black and try to check at the abbot
sorry ultimately there is no way forward
for black so it is the fifth draw for
artists nine sorry the sixth draw um
that's really a accomplishment yeah I
don't think many players are many
experts whatever would have guessed that
he is managing to totus owners so well
him and the draw for caruana certainly
not great him certainly imagine that
with a win he could get back into the
race but it didn't it didn't happen um
and the next game is some kayaking gets
Carlson and yeah I must admit that this
game is some some sort of preparation
mystery to me and I I must confess that
probably this is the case where I simply
don't understand chess well enough to to
to to understand what's going on and we
have the Berlin which is pretty much um
yeah it's not happening all the time
with cards are playing black against you
fall but he's playing it very very often
so it's easily anticipated by kayak
all this has been played we have this
some idea with quick III sss commonly
known and if we look into the database
yeah we see a game from last year linear
dominguez the top cuban player against
David navara from from the Czech
Republic yet exactly the same thing on
the board h6 takes on f7 rupee eight at
first this looks funnier black gives up
the pawn but the night has no way back
and if it is 20 to any any decent engine
it gives exactly this position black is
going to play Bishop e6 this is the
novelty rook f8 was played in the
Navarra game but Bishop t6 is also the
move that any computer here gives and
it's a totally forcing sequence now
Knight takes h6 the night has no square
and then f5 what this looks funny and
interesting add three pawns isn't this
exciting it could be exciting if black
would try to hang on to the bishop which
of course if you look at it only briefly
with the engine it's very apparent that
black shouldn't try something like that
for example yeah miss placing his bishop
like that then this is totally dangerous
those those kind of porn sir we roll but
the computer just gives this and this
and tells the debt equal and I mean what
exactly is sky Atkins idea of a
preparation here he repeats some 18
moves of known theory and then placed
totally harmless sir this is to be
harmless I mean Carson is just drawing
this in his sleep I mean look at the
time spent i mean this is a like
absolutely no effort for the world
champion check the entir they brought
here they can to a draw like a black has
just the active rookie and the checks
till hell freezes over
I don't understand some kind some of
those games unless ur kayaking was
really basically resigned to a draw from
from the outset but do you know that
this is coming on the board and is he
really thinking that Carlton is not
finding this stuff I mean I mean sorry I
would find this stuff and the world
champion I mean really in his sleep yeah
we don't know what what this kind of
preparation is all about I mean if white
is so desperate in them in the Berlin
you should simply play some other
opening I mean play the Italian game or
I don't know they're there must be some
other stuff that can be tried or play
the ultimate NT Berlin 1d4 or c4 or
whatever but I mean this is it's really
not really a game of chess if you play
this against the wallpaper player it
will just end in a draw quite instantly
so kind of a non-game here the next game
is this video game we shook against
swidler yeah two friends playing each
other and we get the same opening that
we had seen before this is quite quite a
trend in top-level chess this this line
and I think there is one reason for that
it is very often played by black players
who like the green felt it is somewhat
Greenfeld ish this idea with the d5 but
they don't want to play the toe the the
the usual anti-griddle Tia what I'm
talking about is this was of course very
a popular for very long time but here
why it has a number of things that he
can try Queen a4 check the capture and
Queen a former queen bee three whatever
and it seems the trend is shifting
towards playing this line which
sometimes can transpose for instance of
white goes deform something like that
can easily transpose to a green felt or
to a very greenford like position here
with III
and there are some other lines of course
that white can tribe independent lines
is free have we had seen in uronian
against the geary and cards and geary
and one point of this move by the way is
that g6 queen bee three is quite nice
for white as the capture after Queen see
three years is fairly ugly for black not
nice black also has to play very ugly
move now like f6 and after that he is
just not very well placed yeah well okay
here if all was played another
interesting continuation which siddhanta
Lee is what what I have played in this
position a number of times with white
night before must be played must be a
active here this is not so great yes
this type of queenless middle game is
quite nice for White King gets knocked
down nicely to c 2 and c 5 is not really
well placed yeah night before as normal
getting for this play and now the check
was given Bishop c4 is also interesting
this yeah and in this position in former
times it was almost mandatory to play
one differ to play d4 him with this kind
of continuation leading to shower plane
which however yet even like 15 to 20
years ago what believed to be totally
equal um d3 now played by ashok an
interesting idea this has a completely
different set up in mind gia get to this
after a five we see a position where
white does not have a super attractive
structure it's not so clear what he's
doing with this but he's very well
developed it has a concrete at DN mind
exactly here after b6 is played yes
Villa wants to give the Pawnee a very
reliable protection b6
um yeah here White has an interesting
idea played by Green shock the movie
form and if you look at the the time
spent this was certainly a prepared
prepared move Knight takes before in
ninety xe5 and fun trade of be against
epon note that the point capture after
95 is not very attractive for black as
this threat and rook takes c6 yeah black
must play something like that which
really looks very unattractive yeah this
was played and this is not bad for black
Bishop p6 gained some time and this this
funny trade happened yeah very
unconventional position but it seems
that at least for gree shook all this
was known he kept playing quickly what's
villa was thinking and yeah the whole
thing is I guess despite being totally
um yeah non-symmetrical is probably
relatively a balance this position Black
has some active player with this bishops
but you must be careful white has a very
nice center and a good knight on d5
however this is also an interesting
factor of the position that the past
poems on the queenside at the moment
however they don't they don't move
quickly forward so it's not a direct
threat you're all this looks fairly
logical I guess white trading queens
here and now we have a very concrete
sequence with Bishop e2 yeah around here
maybe it is possible to look for a white
wide advantage but he didn't enter it in
front any find anything substantial also
the computer didn't didn't find much
here it looks so it looks quite nice for
wide with rook air-five white has the
activity but but how would you actually
again make any headway he took on before
maybe it was more interesting to try the
move d for him kicking them the bishop
back the whole thing however is very
complicated if we consider Bishop g6 and
rook c6 you know it can easily happen
that black can can use the B porn in
connection with the check thus activity
how is white stopping the beep or now
this will prove very difficult it is a
tricky position yeah well Grisha took on
before he played this really quickly may
be here for once decided to [ __ ] it into
time trouble yeah in fact him and the
whole thing has pretty much traded down
to a total equality check yeah and Jim
this back-and-forth business they agreed
to a draw yeah why it has an extra point
even here but totally worthless one
black has the a pond as a compensation
so there's absolutely no way forward
yeah again a very um um unspectacular
game so what about this round isn't it a
bit dull it is a bit dull there was one
remarkable game or ever this is the one
I'm going to come as the game of the day
this is the part of playing kramnik yeah
of course those two players have history
the the initial match in 2006 with the
toilet gate scandal and whatever so they
still don't shake each other's hands and
so on they don't do press conference
together so it is it is more than a game
and for those two to pull off you with
the white pieces he allows the NIMS oh
and now choose the snider three yeah in
fact them the the NIMS 0 is allowing the
NIMS 04 in a way for widest as I believe
the way forward if you want to to get a
battle it it is pretty clear that you
get it on the board as after 9 f 66
black is not going to play the Queens
gambit declined anymore the new measure
is the the opening of choice and here
you can select from a wide range of
possibilities where you can try to set
black problems of course black is
totally fine the demo is probably the
soundest opening there is in chess but
what I'm saying is white being able to
do to predict that it's coming on the
board can choose some some weapon of
choice so the same yeah Knight f3
sometimes called X power of variation
especially this is attributed to
Kasparov as yet plated in the 1986 match
again scalp off with lots of success
kramnik it's not playing c5 this time
however which is this normal move um
curiously enough he plays castles here
and while this doesn't have a bad
reputation it does not have the most
yeah it's not a super established line
as white now manages to set up this pin
and this is some yeah it's not so clear
if black has anything better now then
transposing into this can of regos and
set up he tried the club with c5 unknown
a continuation of course and now this
was played and d5 yeah the thing why I'm
looking at this is opening a bit is that
rather quickly we get a crisis in this
game wyd now played Bishop f6 Queen f6
took on d5 very interesting situation
now and chronic here can play the simple
move we were already by the way I'm out
of establish their theory this hasn't
been played before at least not in my
not too small database um yeah a comic
plays rookie aid so I'm going for some
technically inclined way he also could
have taken on d5 and I don't really
think that this has some some huge
problem attached to it it is an isolated
pawn that's true but black also gets
very easy development if we consider for
example III the most obvious move I
guess yeah white does not have the time
to do something like this yeah yeah this
is immediately leading into trouble with
deform black it's better developed in
this position so III must must be played
and then 96 I mean I really don't think
that this should be anything great for
white no I mean blackest is very very
close to 22 total equality yeah let's
say it should be too and if I really
don't have don't find anything better
I'm just doing this and I really don't
see Kramnik losing this position ever
against anyone it's just a totally sound
for black he can even argue that his
better here and not the first line of
course but I'm just saying that he could
have played the ED 5 with a simple and
good game i believe rocked the eight as
mentioned III now he takes d5 is not as
pointed and it's not clear that the roof
belongs on the head but anyway it was
clearly wanted to do this yeah giving
making some sense of the rook tightness
and now queen bee three yeah this is
really a curious situation now um yeah
here
chrome dick basically has a choice he
can admit that the whole thing is not
leading to much and play em some yeah
not very inspiring move like taking an
example and then go back this is not as
stupid as it looks I mean it looks ya
like like a meek continuation but it is
not that terrible I mean if we look at
this we should be to Bishop d7 and 96
coming this is not the terrible position
for black maybe the issue that he had
was that Quincy eight is a possibility
good chair could be the case check this
is a interesting continuation from white
looking at this point yeah the black
should be okay here Bishop e7 and term
White's pieces don't have any any good
coordination this this saw this coming
and I mean it was possible to play in
this way at however it's probably not
the continuation that chrome league
wants to play against his is yeah no
enemy number one so to say being this
the sort of setting up this sort of a
passive defense he decided to sacrifice
the exchange on deform and I want to be
honest I don't really think that this is
this is totally sound takes because and
96 we see blacks idea you will get this
default pawn that's pretty much clear
and then you will have a pawn for the
exchange but the question is is it
really enough let's look at the game
bishop we should be five queen f form
this is necessary to get the pawn at all
castles 94 and Queen to d1 this is
pretty much forced and the the problem
in a way is that black has got the porn
it's got two bishops he's got a
possibility to to even anchor his night
in the middle of the board but still
he's not very well developed this is a
big problem the bishop is on c8 and the
rookies on it they don't play and black
really has to make some concessions to
get those pieces into the game and here
he at the end decided to take on c3 and
I think after that it is very clear that
this is an insufficient sacrifice that
he made maybe still Bishop a5 needed to
be tried trying to play the Bishop to b6
but it still stays on c8 the other
bishop yeah and to us I cannot really
believe that this is enough for the
exchange it's not like totally off but
it seems to favor wide I believe after
the capture we pretty quickly see that
it is unselfish and rook takes and e5 we
are getting the bishop out Bishop c4
looking at this diagonal maybe intending
Bishop g5 Bishop d7 Quincy one trying to
exchange Queens ok this was avoided and
now the Queen has a nice post on e3 and
now we see a very important to maneuver
after Bishop c6 the only sensible place
from the bishop wyd regroups and this is
a very strong regrouping the bishop to
e4 very simple but very strong yeah it
identifying that the bishop wants is six
is a very strong piece white tries to
exchange this piece of course the d4
night is also very strong certainly the
best piece that black hairs but of
course you cannot exchange it easily you
would need a look for that and you don't
want to return the exchange after this
this Bishop d3 d4 maneuver these pieces
get traded or black loses coordination
and this is what happens in our white
enters on the seventh-ranked yeah around
here the position um enter some there
the yeah it's a winning position now for
white black can only try to to muddy the
waters to convey 2 & 1 a 2 sorry why it
takes on b7 now a 6 was played yeah note
that Queen takes after rugby one wasn't
really great too much on the bishop yeah
a six and now be three yeah and b3 is
quite a nice smooth it makes sure that
this diagonal is blocked and white now
intends to join bed eros IAM intends to
put the bishop on d5 and get this
pressure on f7 going which would be a
absolutely overwhelming yeah black
really has no defense the the only thing
is the way that chrome Nick played it
was dead embarrassing because he played
rugby aid and there was still Bishop g5
and he really didn't have a good move
but Bishop the rook the eighth is just
somewhat funny as it looks like it
prevents Bishop b5 but it's of course
still playable as black cannot really
capture due to check the eighth king age
70 with a 4 and the rook is falling yeah
so Bishop g5 was played yeah and now
black is really in dire straits f7 has
also gone now he tried it with the check
and night f4 yeah Jack why just why just
takes this
now queen bee 6 was played yeah this is
a not the most precise move it seems if
you ask our silicon frontier it gives
rook v6 looks a tad mysterious at first
what is this doing but if you look at it
in a bit more detail you you see the
point one important point is that it in
a way keeps the night on F for the night
cannot move after 92 for example white
check we're very quickly an eight spot
this checkmate quite quite a sudden son
end to the game if the night would move
route b6 was very strong night bc Queen
B 6 also looks good it attacks the rook
and everything but it is not as
convincing we see that after Queen d1
crook g1 this was necessary roop was a
tech and it didn't have any other square
to go to that black here I could have
played but he didn't he could have
played a continuation that still would
have put up some resistance this is
Knight to h3 looks funny but it has an
idea after the capture there is Bishop
e2 and Bishop f3 check is a very
substantial substantial threat in fact
this is so substantial after Queen c6
Queen d3 renewing the threat white must
play Bishop g5 and check yeah well this
position here is still winning for white
but yet he can continue it's not so easy
why it is not easily winning the apron
as it is n cardioid is protected by the
bishop and whites pawn structure is very
rekt white should win but this was some
way to continue Kramnik played king edge
then maybe you saw it in sand and said
okay this is winning for white anyway
and well there really isn't down any
great continuation
a tree the kind of keep it safe move not
doing anything fancy white its of course
clearly up in material and it's also
just attacking black without any any
need for fancy play there were more
direct ways to play rugby aid for
example also very effective but this was
just just okay it keeps the win and does
not make it difficult yeah Queen c7
looking at the square on g7 like Bishop
GA check yeah it was the only way to
continue but blackest of just only
Buster check check took this walk with
the King all the way to f5 probably two
discussed it to to resign no bishop age
five little tactical stroke after this
check wyd regains the material notice of
course completely winning yeah it only
this was played actually I'm sorry I
didn't really know that was played yeah
i actually had stopped my genders as a
couple of moves earlier because i offer
as a thought okay it's totally winning
no need to prepare anything on that yet
yep here Kramnik Kramnik resigned the
game and he was a as i read totally
frustrated and and left the whole the
whole venue without i think showing up
at the press conference i'm not quite
sure about that don't want to tell
anything wrong but it did it seemed that
he was really really am mmm really very
angry at himself i guess for for this
game yeah especially in losing this dike
that is no not fun at all and doing this
against his nemesis is certainly a
certainly terrible
still tough to understand in a way I
mean right here maybe he thought that
rook t5 was actually yeah an
enterprising continuation that gives him
better chances even but he takes d5 and
in the 96 was very solid way to play and
I don't really see any big drawback
especially before the eight rows of
light applause so around route here yeah
I mean you can look at this further but
something like that for example is
simply not not great for white because
of the development the kingside is still
is still not not out and Joan something
like that I don't really know but this
looks fine to me Black is very active
and something like this Bishop g4 he's
got everything or pieces are in play and
black should be it totally okay here so
i'm a bit mystified why he didn't go for
that maybe he just overestimated his
chances with rook da droop d5 it looks
active at first but it does not really
seem to to work out as planned so after
this round we have the funny situation
that we have three players leading the
tournament with a somewhat meager plus
one score kawana still of course Kramnik
after this loss down to +1 and Carlton
threw a champion also on +1 so it is
wide open even the guys on fifty percent
can still win it of course um it's a
wide-open race now every everybody
almost has sense chances yeah okay I
hope you enjoyed the coverage of the
sixth round it wasn't the most exciting
round
but still some some interesting points
to enjoy in the games I think we have
around seven tomorrow the rest days only
after the seventh round so looking
forward to cover this upcoming round
tomorrow thanks for watching and I'll be
back with round seven coverage I'm